Transcriptor: Anna Sobota
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Vamos a empezar con
un breve ejercicio de imaginación.
¿Cuál de las siguientes dos imágenes
creéis que representa mejor
vuestros dos últimos años?
¿Os parece?
¿Sí? Esto es interactivo.
¿Vale?
(Risas)
Gracias.
La primera imagen:
estáis tumbados en la playa, relajados.
Arena fina de color blanco,
agua cristalina,
un azul turquesa.
Una suave brisa os acaricia
y os quita el calor del verano.
Primera imagen.
La segunda imagen:
estáis en medio del mar.
Un barquito pequeñito. Vais remando.
No sabéis bien hacia dónde vais.
Pero más o menos intuyes
que debe ser por ahí.
De vez en cuando paras y sacas
un poco de agua.
Olas golpean de lado a lado
y en el fondo se atisban unos nubarrones.
¿Qué imagen tenéis más asociada?
Levantad la mano, la primera, por favor.
Genial.
La segunda, por favor.
(Risas)
No sé qué pasa en Tarragona.
Perdón.
No sé lo que ocurre que, de repente,
nunca antes hemos estado expuestos
a tanta incertidumbre.
¿Cuándo nos podremos
quitar la mascarilla?
¿Lo sabemos?
¿Cómo vamos a pagar toda la
deuda que ha generado esta pandemia?
¿Cuándo dejará de haber pandemia?
¡Ah! Lo del cambio climático.
Es importante. ¿Una transición?
Las transiciones son fáciles, ¿no?
¿Y la desigualdad? Económica, de género...
¡Ostras!
¿Y todo esto en los próximos años?
No tenemos ni idea de lo que va
a ocurrir en el futuro más cercano.
El hombre nunca antes ha estado
tan expuesto a la intemperie.
Así que, supongo que os debe
pasar lo mismo que a mí.
Yo me levanto por la mañana y recuerdo
la ley universal del aprendizaje, ¿verdad?
Todos la conocéis, es lo que nos ha
llevado como especie hasta aquí.
¿Sí? Todos la sabéis, ¿verdad?
¿Alguien no la sabe?
Levantad la mano, por favor.
¡Fantástico!
¿Dónde estudiasteis?
(Risas)
Vale.
La ley universal del aprendizaje
dice una cosa muy simple:
las personas, las organizaciones
y la sociedad
para sobrevivir necesitan aprender
al menos a la misma velocidad
a la que cambia el entorno.
Y para progresar,
necesitan aprender más rápido.
Así que, la pregunta siguiente es fácil.
¿Vosotros aprendéis más rápido,
igual o más lento que vuestro entorno?
No hace falta que lo contestéis,
id pensando.
(Risas)
Por la risa entiendo
que más rápido.
(Risas)
Pero antes de poder contestar
a esta pregunta,
seguro que os habéis preguntado,
¿y esto cómo lo puedo averiguar?
Es fácil.
Entiendo que todos tenemos
una libreta de aprendizajes del año.
Si estamos casi al final de año,
la estoy recuperando.
Es el sitio donde apuntáis
las tres o cuatro cosas
que habéis aprendido
cada uno de los años.
Y de vez en cuando revisáis para decir:
“Voy progresando,
voy en la buena dirección”.
Todo el mundo tiene una.
Nuestro cerebro es incapaz de recordar
todas las cosas que aprendemos.
Ya casi no recordamos números de teléfono.
Imagínate los aprendizajes del año 2015.
¿Cuáles son?
Así que, si os parece,
vamos a revisar las tres cosas
que habéis aprendido el último año.
¿Sí?
Fíjate que cuando reflexionas
sobre el aprendizaje,
te obligas a mirarte al espejo.
De repente, para reflexionar
sobre lo aprendido,
te miras al espejo
y miras hacia dentro de ti.
Es ahí donde cobra mucho más sentido
la palabra “aprender”.
¿Qué significa aprender?
Aprender es
prender cosas hacia ti.
Así que, id pensando que tres cosas
habéis prendido hacia ti
y ya forman parte de vosotros.
Si os parece empiezo yo, ¿vale?
Yo lo llevo preparado.
(Risas)
Tres aprendizajes de este año.
Muy fácil y muy simple.
Primer aprendizaje:
he aprendido todo sobre
el mundo de los datos.
Oímos hablar constantemente de que
los datos son importantes,
que es el nuevo petróleo, dicen algunos.
Hay empresas haciendo
negocios multimillonarios
alrededor del mundo de los datos.
Por otro lado, cada vez tenemos más
datos sobre nosotros mismos.
¿Cuántos pasos anduvisteis ayer?
¿Cuántos lo sabéis?
Si le preguntarías a vuestro yo
de hace veinte años:
“¿Cuántos pasos andas?”
Diría: “Estás muy raro”.
¿No?
De repente empezamos a tener
datos un poco absurdos.
¿Qué tal la calidad del sueño
de la semana pasada?
Ha disminuido.
De repente nos damos cuenta de que
tenemos datos a nuestro alrededor
sobre nosotros mismos
y esto nos ayuda a conocernos mejor.
Por otro lado, lo que también nos preocupa
es que estos datos, en verdad,
¿son vuestros?
¿O son de la empresa del reloj?
No lo sé... Es raro.
De repente, mi primer aprendizaje
es sobre el mundo de los datos
y cómo los datos afectan a las personas,
a las empresas y a la sociedad.
Como personas, nadie
nos ha enseñado a leer datos,
nadie nos ha enseñado
a trabajar con datos,
a comunicarnos con datos.
Desde la óptica de la empresa
se toman decisiones aún por intuición,
por lo que dice el jefe
y por su experiencia.
Y no tanto con datos.
Y desde el ámbito de la sociedad,
ni siquiera hemos empezado a reflexionar
dónde están nuestros datos
y cómo los vamos a recuperar.
Así que, mi primer aprendizaje
tiene que ver con los datos.
¿Sí? ¿Mola? Vale.
Segundo aprendizaje. Importantísimo.
He aprendido a jugar partidos de tenis.
Jugar partidos de tenis no es lo mismo
que jugar al tenis.
Jugar al tenis tiene que ver
con darle golpes a una pelotita,
y más o menos intentar dirigirla.
Jugar partidos de tenis,
iba a decir ganar,
pero es verdad
que cuando juegas partidos de tenis
pierdes algunos.
Entonces, implica conocerte a ti mismo.
Implica entender al rival.
Y mientras una pelotita va y viene,
si te toca ir adaptando,
intentando ver por dónde
puedes ir ganando puntos.
Esto es el segundo
gran aprendizaje.
El tercer gran aprendizaje
tiene que ver con mis hábitos.
Nuestros hábitos nos definen.
Hay hábitos y hábitos malos.
Cuando te levantas seguro
que no hay nadie
que mira el móvil nada más levantarse.
Nadie, ¿verdad?
Fíjate que los hábitos son necesarios.
El cerebro no puede
estar todo el día pensando:
voy a coger el móvil, ¿sí o no?
¿Tú qué piensas?
¿Sí o no?
El cerebro tiene que activarse.
Entonces hay gente, me han dicho,
que se levanta, mira el móvil,
luego va a tomarse un café
mirando el móvil,
luego se va a la ducha, deja el móvil,
se viste, deja el móvil
y a partir de ahí arranca su día.
Resulta que mi tercer gran aprendizaje
tiene que ver con identificar
aquellos hábitos buenos
y aquellos hábitos malos.
Los hábitos buenos,
intentar potenciarlos.
Los hábitos malos,
intentar cambiarlos.
Estos son mis
tres grandes aprendizajes del año.
No está mal para lo que llevamos de año.
Ahora, los doce minutos que me quedan
restantes, vamos a hablar de tenis.
(Risas)
Tenis.
¿Te imaginas?
Perdón, lo tenía que decir.
Es lo que tienen los hobbies, que hay
una barrera que si la cruzas
ya se vuelven en obsesiones
y están presentes en todo.
Me gustaría hablar sobre aprendizaje.
¿Os parece?
Creo que para poder sacar
estos tres grandes aprendizajes,
uno tiene que tener una fórmula mágica
para poder aprender.
Si os parece,
les voy a compartir la mía.
Para poder aprender de forma eficaz
y más rápido que el entorno,
que es a lo que veníamos hablando,
necesitas tres grandes cosas.
La primera es, tu aprendes gracias
al entorno.
Dependiendo de lo que tengas en casa,
aprendes de una manera u otra.
Fíjate, hay una estadística
que me gusta mucho que dice que
ocho de los diez últimos campeones del
mundo de los 100 metros lisos,
dentro de una familia numerosa,
eran el hijo más pequeño.
Así que, es una gran demostración
de que para aprender a correr,
sigue siendo el último hijo.
En casa te enseñan.
Dicho esto:
el entorno te ayuda
y te ayuda a aprender más rápido.
En mi caso, mi profesión no se puede
definir por lo que yo he estudiado.
Yo no tengo la suerte
como los ingenieros o los arquitectos.
“¿Tú quién eres?”
“Ingeniero.” “¡Ah! Vale”.
Yo hago varias cosas al mismo tiempo.
Me gusta definirme como:
soy un perfil A, B, C.
A de Académico, B de Business,
C de Consultor.
Son mis tres dedicaciones.
Hago tres cosas al mismo tiempo.
La académica es:
me gusta dar clases.
Esta es mi primera conferencia en público.
Estoy nervioso.
Me gusta dar clases, me gusta enseñar,
me gusta estructurar el conocimiento
y darle diferentes formas.
Esta labor didáctica me llena
y me ayuda a aprender
porque me obliga a mirar hacia atrás.
Te obliga a mirar hacia el pasado.
La B de business.
Todos los que tenéis negocio
ya sabéis de que hablo, es día a día.
Estás todo el día sacando agua
o intentando remar hacia algún lado.
Tengo un negocio que trata de cómo
la tecnología puede ayudar al aprendizaje
y claro, este sector
cambia muy rápido
y continuamente tenemos cosas
que hacer, el día a día.
La C de consultor.
Viene gente y te dice:
“¿Cómo crees que me afectará esto
en el futuro?”
y te obliga a coger
la bola de cristal y decir:
“Pues más o menos yo creo
que esto irá por ahí”.
Mi entorno de aprendizaje
me obliga a tres miradas:
una, hacia atrás;
dónde me obliga a recopilar
lo aprendido para poderlo exponer.
La segunda, hacia el presente.
Y la tercera, hacia el futuro.
Solo en entornos profesionales
de aprendizaje somos capaces
de aprender muy rápido
gracias al entorno.
Gracias.
(Risas)
La segunda gran variable
para un aprendizaje eficaz
tiene que ver con tener un método.
Y es aquí donde os debería
de preguntar,
¿y vosotros como vais a recordar
todo esto?
¿Dónde estáis tomando notas?
Sólo hay dos personas en primera fila
tomando notas, ¿y el resto?
Ah, mira. Por ahí hay alguien.
Tengo una teoría últimamente
y la voy a soltar aquí.
Frente a la información,
tú tienes dos actitudes:
o es entretenimiento
o es aprendizaje.
No paramos de recibir información.
Muchas de las charlas que
hemos oído hoy son espectaculares,
hay mucho aprendizaje ahí.
¿Cómo lo vais a retener?
Seguro que alguno puede decir:
miraré el vídeo más adelante.
Sí... Ya estuviste aquí.
No sé si lo vais a repetir...
Creo que o tenéis un sistema para ir
seleccionando la información que es útil
o probablemente se borrará.
Venís aquí para inspiraros.
Fíjate, la palabra “inspirar”
es “coger aire”.
Pero luego lo tienes que soltar
por algún lado.
Entonces necesitamos todos
un método para poder aprender.
En mi caso, mi método es simple.
Yo en su día hice un mapa de conocimiento
de todas las cosas que sé.
Os preguntaréis:
¿Y cómo sabes lo que sabes?
Buena pregunta.
Lo que hice es poner
tres grandes bloques.
El primero, casilla verde:
soy capaz de explicar esto
durante más de 20 minutos.
Casilla amarilla:  soy capaz de explicar
esto, pero igual no tanto como 20 minutos
o este tema está cambiando tanto que
probablemente no seré preciso.
Casilla roja: de esto no sé
y me gustaría aprender.
Gracias a tener un mapa del conocimiento
mi atención se dirige.
Durante los dos últimos años solo me
he interesado por hábitos, data y tenis.
Lo siento...
(Risas)
Hábito y data.
Toda la información que leía
por todos lados es:
¿Esto tiene que ver con estos
dos grandes temas?
No, pues fuera.
Todo lo iba guardando,
lo iba estructurando, lo iba escribiendo,
iba haciéndome un esquema
y lo iba compartiendo.
En base a lo que me decía la gente
lo corregía y lo volvía a compartir.
Y gracias a este método de trabajar
solo pocas cosas pero muy focalizadas,
me ha permitido poder aprender
y poder decir:
de estos temas soy capaz de explicar
durante más de 20 minutos.
La tercera variable para el aprendizaje
tiene que ver con la emoción.
Si tú no sabes por qué
o para qué quieres aprender
muy probablemente esto
no te emocionará.
En la edad adulta, en el aprendizaje,
hay cinco grandes razones
por las cuales tú quieres aprender.
La primera es, cuando estás perdido
y no tienes un punto de referencia.
En algún momento de vuestra vida
os vais a perder.
Entonces el aprendizaje te ayuda y te da
guías para dirigirte hacia algún lado,
te orienta.
La segunda razón por la cual
nos gusta aprender
es porque nos ayuda a resolver
problemas del día a día.
Tengo un problema: lo investigo,
lo soluciono y lo incorporo.
La tercera razón, es porque así me permite
tener una nueva línea en LinkedIn
y es una mejora de mi currículum
y esto me ayudará profesionalmente.
La cuarta razón, tiene que
ver con el estatus.
Gracias a aprender, yo sé más que tú
y te puedo contar cosas.
Esto me da prestigio y este estatus
me ayuda a querer seguir aprendiendo.
Y la quinta razón es que nos
ayuda a entender el mundo.
En mi caso, esta es la quinta.
Cuando te enfrentas a un alumno
hoy en día,
los alumnos vienen leídos de casa.
Muchos te cuestionan lo que sabes
y en ese momento te das cuenta de que
tu conocimiento tiene
diferentes ángulos.
Cada vez que te acercas más a la verdad,
hay muchos matices que la hacen
mucho más compleja.
Aprender implica llegar hasta el final
y entender cada uno de los matices
y cada uno de los ángulos posibles.
Y esa es la motivación que me llega.
Así que, si queréis aprender,
tres cosas:
Primero de todo,
pensad en vuestro entorno.
Segundo, revisad el método.
Tercero, entender la razón
por la cual aprendéis.
Dicho esto, seguro que hay más de uno
en la audiencia pensando:
A ver, tío. Nos la has colado.
¿Tres aprendizajes?
¡El entorno cambia más rápido!
A ti te va a pasar la ola por encima.
¿Verdad? A qué estáis pensando esto.
Bueno, por si acaso.
Y yo os lo digo, es así.
Yo como individuo lo tengo mal
frente a un entorno tan cambiante.
Pero fíjate lo que dice
la ley universal del aprendizaje.
Dice: las personas, las organizaciones
y la sociedad.
Fíjate que si cada uno de los que
estáis aquí compartierais
tres aprendizajes del último año,
tendríamos más de 1500 aprendizajes.
Compartir lo aprendido es el único
mecanismo desde siempre
para poder sobrevivir
a un entorno tan cambiante.
No lo digo yo, lo dice la historia.
En un momento dado de la historia
coincidieron dos especies
de seres humanos.
Lo conocéis, ¿verdad?
Los homo sapiens
y los neandertales.
Los neandertales eran más fuertes,
más rápidos.
Ostras, lo tenían todo para adaptarse.
Y los Homo sapiens, ¿qué tenían?
Bueno, sí... Se dice que pensaban.
Pero gracias a pensar
consiguieron dos cosas:
fueron capaces de desarrollar tecnologías
para modificar el entorno
y la siguiente cosa es,
fueron capaces de colaborar a escala
compartiendo aprendizaje.
Eso está dentro de nuestro ADN.
Si queremos realmente sobrevivir
a un entorno tan cambiante,
lo que deberíamos de hacer
es compartir lo aprendido.
Muchas gracias por vuestra atención.
(Aplausos)